[Music]
[Applause] It's
really delicious. Eat it.
[Music]
It's got chocolate in it,
but it's not a lot. It's empty inside. There's some
chocolate in me, and it's in
moderation, so it's not burdensome.
[Music]
But it's still something Korean snack, something Korean food.  I kept
eating one thing after another,
but sometimes, why did they prepare it in the waiting room
so much?
[Applause] Wow [
Music] [
Music]
Yes, this is
delicious, but it's also
a bit fun. And this is a bit tmi, but there
was a hair rule when I was in middle school.
All the students
went to school like that in the past. If you
look at their actual graduation photos, they had Dai's hair, so they
said it was Choco Song's hair.
But these Cheetos are really
different depending on the country. I bought American Cheetos, and I took them home to see if they were a little saltier.  I'm
trying to say that you
can eat all kinds of spiciness, but you
can eat it really, really spicy.
That's why our
album is also
spicy. Just like
people are addicted to spicy food, I think many of us at Neverland will be really addicted to it.
[Applause]
But it's really very
spicy.  That's right, there's
really just fire chicken stir-fry noodles, and I think this one is a bit
spicy and not too spicy.
In Korea, it
feels like it's a bit focused on spiciness, so if there's something spicy,
you ask a little bit. It's about fire
chicken stir-fry noodles. I think it's become a standard to ask like this.
[Music]